welcome James it's been a long time
finally here we are mark the date bond
fans on November 6 2015 a double oh
seven movie finally asked is James Bond
obsolete no it's not asking if James
Bond finally got himself into a jam he
can't get himself out of that'll never
happen instead it wants to know whether
in this age of mass surveillance and
oversharing do we even need super spies
Spectre the 24th film in the Bond
franchise asked this on two levels the
first is the movie subplot which focuses
on see the new head of the Joint
Intelligence Service set on eradicated a
double o program in replacing field
agents with multi government wiretapping
and drones you don't know what you're
doing it's from possible it's the future
the second level is a more philosophical
question are we over James Bond I can
think of worse ways to go the answer to
the problem see presents is simple no in
the world of bond there will always be
some maniacal millionaire that no amount
of digital eavesdropping can bring down
take note NSA why given every other
possible option doesn't manage was the
life of a paid assassin well it was that
or the priesthood the answer to the
second problem is more complicated on
the surface Spector has all the best of
bond car chases dr. no vibes the perfect
bad guy in Christoph Waltz it's for
example you must know by now that the
double-o program is officially dead it's
too great bond woman in monica bellucci
and lea seydoux and of course martinis
but it's 2015 chauvinism and excessive
drinking aren't as cool as they used to
be the smooth license to kill thing has
been around for decades and maybe it's
time is up Spectre is terribly aware of
this an even current bond Daniel Craig
is acting a bit bored with
double-oh-seven santak seeeeee watching
Specter it's hard not to wonder if bond
has run his course or at least wonder
should we all move on to the Kingsmen
nah Spectre may not be the best Bond it
may not even be as good as the last
double-oh-seven movie Skyfall okay it's
definitely not but it's still a hell of
a lot of fun
it's got all the improbable action and
romantic trysts you'd expect from a bond
movie but also just enough
self-awareness to make it not feel like
it's trying too hard Spectre shows the
bonds days may be numbered but then
again they always were why did you come
I came here to kill you and I thought
you came here to die well it's all a
matter of perspective